[Applause]
[Music]
big [ __ ] that's why I said anytime I
need a basket I want to broaden that jab
stick you got to step back that's three
straight offensive rebounds and refuse
by the closing seconds down to half a
second when Parramatta let that one go
Spence seven footer from Colorado State
he's matched up with Henson right now
with a deep kiss how did they get that
through Elias Silva that was pretty deep
eight points for him you can't see the
Sun they're floor to ceiling with
Anthony whose money rotted up very nice
one would have had an open look a short
between the middle of them nobody gets
one Melo at the buzzer
Carmelo Anthony count the basket
[Applause]
loosen it can be abusive to likely
westbrook if you're allowing the
penetrating
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello a second time look like he's on a
trampoline
nasty sassy stuff by memo
looks like the boots right all the guys
are the [ __ ] off the bench 15 of the
first half
Larry 10 in the second quarter alone is
everything draws a foul they give you
the continuous 60 right there gives up
the baseline to belated attempt by Adams
that was missing earlier piece of the
first town hold pushing the other way
finds Anthony Anthony three-pointer and
the Knicks off to an excellent start
[Music]
ludo John here and through the jab step
- the second a long time walking down
locos finds handsome
[Music]
down a lane running shot again too
strong off the glass yet but he gets it
back has to put it
[Applause]
this is personified by Melo this is the
shy far back baby jumper Sefolosha is on
an excellent job on Anthony Anthony now
drives gets inside baseline cut for the
stuffing Danny let's take another look
so nice you're twice
[Applause]
it appeared he was trying to get the
young man
[Applause]
look at them together you're not fun I
don't know figures yelling sound
get up because why are you dropping off
you don't want him to take the three so
you get up on if you try to force him
inside of the dexterity utilize it in
left hand model seconds here comes
Anthony it's gone what a first quarter
for Carmelo Anthony he goes 5 of 6
Thomas matched up with the rookie REO
his own young Jason Smith here in the
first half
Lowrey baseline comes out the other side
Melo puts a little more to look at ruled
the two on the floor but that's three
straight buckets for Carmelo Anthony of
the smaller and slower platonovitch
Raptors do not have a foul to give
Anthony shoots scores at the buzzer
Carmelo Anthony wraps up a terrific
first half and don't mess was open an
anthony mr. Anthony now takes a
contested shot back sit in at the buzzer
Carmelo Anthony will go in gum ass tip
misses rebound out to Anthony Anthony
pull-up jumper it's good puzzle capping
off a sensational opening quarter for
Anthony give although they don't want to
use it here Anthony trying to clear up
kidd-gilchrist on him Rose comes back
Anthony backs in turns puts it up
[Applause]
this time he wants the right side he's
got lickin time him single coverage
Anthony fakes puts up the jumper cuts a
time with 2.3 with 84 mellow it that he
nails it and the Knicks lead by 2
the work for 14 is through up an air
ball just a couple of shots ago with
confidence knocks down the big jumper
and now the Knicks need a stop ball
deflected by Rose we've also seen Rose
play some good solid defense ahead to
Anthony nicely
advance pass and Anthony the finish and
that's the pace tunics need to play
tonight the second opportunity as well
for Villa needs it's down to again
alley-oop Anthony throws it down
beautiful Rose finds Anthony again
Anthony here comes the double-team
shoots over and connects the buzzer
Carmelo Anthony struggling shooting the
ball in the quarter we see McGruder only
5/4 6/4 Melo six eight catches it puts
it in I was alluding to he's got has a
very efficient at the timeouts Harris
gets it back
oh so trying to change that tonight
right here beating the clock so dramatic
finished
[Applause]
teams have been resilient that 12-lead
cities is already shot clock winding
down as Anthony fires at hits do not
have a foul to give here
Anthony catches one dribble
[Applause]
Anthony from downtown will take a
one-point lead into the locker room
mastering clock efficiency Hardaway
should take away two right hand he did
not mellow makes them pay 17 first half
points for Anthony and a smart timeout
to set everything up even though Rose
Lowe's them lost the ball Hawks do not
have a foul to give
Anthony spins falling away that's good
puzzle
second time Melo and to put two of his
bounces by Melo on his last two shots
Anthony 9 of 13 from the field his
grapes at 5 porzingis porzingis lost his
left sneaker that day hits another 3
that's his fourth
today Millsap on him six seconds drives
inside he got hit man he tied the
ballgame up with 2.6 mark slap playing
smart where's the double-team look at
guys looking as he goes to do no one's
coming over to contestant yeah that was
Millsap did that at New York in that
close game look at this look at the
Hawks though no one to cover the help he
delivers the deuce and we're tied again
minutes in these last two save the day
for the moment yeah both they've come in
that same area Mike along the baseline
with the follow a jumper Melo 7n1
because he lost his headband Hardaway
Macklin blocked it off his head right
there it didn't fall off on its own
Anthony drives draws the foul
muche right on top of them and Anthony
with a veteran play hey little knock it
down early in the morning for one of his
workouts having one of his rough games
Anthony got hit and finishes push the
foul and Melo cannot be stopped in his
first quarter covington three seconds
Carmelo shoot Oh does well-defended
can't stop that beeps a weapon in the
game has ever seen yep 38,000 career
quarter
Meritage to fall down on a crossover and
the Nets back up by 21 game Melo Willie
to deal in it no matter where
[Applause]
exit Melo Anthony had his back to the
basket with a last-minute turn seven
shooting
[Applause]
now I agree with you Indiana shooting
nine of 24
[Applause]
but let us got a chance to establish a
tutor session lead
and this is another foul ball the cargo
mellow ID advantage against JR Smith
well what a move by Carmelo Anthony how
many times have we seen that welcome I
not see could do it on either side after
he found out he was traded he had been
putting on weight to play the bases and
do a lot of things for them as Melo it's
down that stair down three only 1 of 9
from three atoms with the block home
Gortat here fourth block of the ball
game for Oklahoma City
Anthony is going to drive he's gonna
pack it and he's going to go to the
free-throw line and walk nice will cross
little border got there too late
if it catches a break
Melo gets the countdown and face nice
sin have the smaller Cory Joseph they're
waiting for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
five to shoot no is it a tough spot I've
got to get off the shot no problem
they're already looking at it with a bit
of a trained eye Nolan he's gonna go
through and get this for me he's got to
get up high get him back mellow mellow
triggering CJ holding sweeps him low to
the floor outside
Carmelo Anthony drills it straight away
from 16 feet out 3 and 3/10 seconds
remaining in this baby and the Blazers
take a lead at to force the issue he
doesn't feel like he has the clear look
and you see the defender up top with
Damien he's stuck with him he's not
letting game open right here so that
just gives Melo
even more of a drive in Lane 2 half
Spelman guarding Anthony stops on a dime
and puts up that chap step range it's
just an outlier there's the little
chicken wing with that right arm to kind
of create space versus Spelman and they
end up winning in Utah Mike D'Antoni
sets put the most satisfying wins I've
had in the NBA six points moved into
sole possession of 17th on the all-time
scoring list terminates the dribble gets
it back from a reason faces up with two
to shoot lets it fly got it perfect
timing
[Applause]
buries it from outside all right the
Blazers come out three minutes got by re
should say three minutes left here in
the corner and a nice lob inside sach
double to CJ they force the ball out of
his hands to Carmelo and he snugs in a
trouble